the winner
[Applause]
od
you did it buddy you all did it oh my
god good to see everybody again bit of a
full-circle moment cuz I got to chat
with you and meet your family right
after the golden buzzer moment how does
it feel to win a GT it was unbelievable
what was it like being up there and
seeing him really across the finish line
and win America's heart I was so proud
of them because he didn't just win the
whole world won right because he's
changing the world and he's opening
doors for all the kids and I mean just
that right there is what's amazing
Cody what was it like to be up there
singing with Leona Lewis you guys did
such a beautiful beautiful job thank ya
[Laughter]
you really did it was so beautiful right
I think you guys need to record it Wow
was it mean to share this entire moment
with your family and having all your
brothers and sisters your mom and dad
here oh my gosh I love my brother
how cool is it you guys to see him in
this huge arena on this big platform and
on and win the whole thing thing I mean
really I'm just like beyond proud of
them you guys know how you're gonna
spend the million dollar prize every
color you need the whole spectrum the
whole rainbow red yellow orange green
blue on the black forgot the black mom
were you gonna store all these grandpa
maybe buy the new house and then all the
grand pianos so much emotion I mean your
adrenalin went whoa I mean your boy yeah
yes what's been so proud so proud like
when we got down to Detroit youth choir
and Cody Lee it was a win win no matter
what
I just incredibly proud of all the
contestants tonight and and it's never
entertaining to me when wouldn't dreams
are crushed and certainly of children
and on national television but it was a
huge moment a huge huge moment obviously
you hit your golden buzzer for Cody
little did you know he was gonna win
this whole dang thing would it mean to
see him take it home the bigger picture
is that he literally did really change
the world and and he's going to change
the opportunities for so many families
who need the resources the attention and
the love and the opportunities so we can
truly create a level playing field and
truly be inclusive of all talent and
giving everyone a real chance at at you
know winning this special we're really
wet right yeah way beyond this
competition I mean you have any advice
for him now that he's about to enter
this next exciting new chapter make sure
it's fun save fun because when it's not
fun it will feel like a job and this is
this is a dream so when it starts to
feel like a job he's so talented he has
so many dreams I just want them to all
be filled with a lot of joy it's amazing
to hear you say that because I could
tell you had a lot of fun doing this
I think what are the chances we can get
you back on the judges panel next season
you I don't know I don't know there's a
lot of amazing things happening and I
but I loved I loved this show and I
loved the opportunity of being a part of
people's dreams coming true you know I'm
I'm on the talent side where I get
rejected every day and it was nice to
really kind of just go a little bit
deeper with each contestant and really
be a part of their dream and I took it
personally when people didn't make it
through so I don't know I'm not just
doing this you really don't have me back